france avec un maillot jaune qui
changent encore des pôles schumacher
victime d'une chute et détrôner ce soir
par le luxembourgeois kirschen et c'est
un jeune espoir italien
ricco qui remporte l'étape sur place
nathanaël de rincquesen régis mater
depuis le début du tour c'est presque
devenu une tradition chaque jour dès les
premiers kilomètres de l'étape des
coureurs français faussé compagnie au
peloton
cima chabanel benoît vaugrenard et
freddy bichot multiplie les efforts
pendant 180 km sur les routes du massif
central
les trois hommes doivent se battre
contre la route qui s'élève le soleil
qui tape le peloton qui revient et
l'appui qui glace ça fait beaucoup pour
des échappées la chaleur on a pris un
coup
aujourd'hui ce qui a permis de refroidir
un petit peu ça reste toujours des
journées difficiles parce qu'il n'y a
pas trop de quatre autres plats c'est
toujours en prise et tout le monde
connaît mais si central s'est hissé dans
le peloton la tension est palpable
cadel evans s'énerve contre un gendarme
qui a failli faire tomber
chavanel lui arrête les frais à 15
kilomètres de l'arrivée il a récupéré le
maillot de meilleur grimpeur
l'échappée est terminée débute alors une
nouvelle course riche en intensité en
rebondissements à 300 mètres de la ligne
stefan schumacher le maillot jaune
heurte la route d'un concurrent
il perd l'équilibré 32 secondes et sa
précieuse tunique pour cette première
arrivée au sommet valverde et evans sont
roue dans roue mais c'est ricardo ricco
l'italien qui s'imposent
les transalpins voient en lui le futur
pantani et en italie c'est un compliment
sur le podium
kim kirchen a sorti son plus beau
sourire depuis charlie gaulle il ya 50
ans aucun luxembourgeois n'avait porté
le maillot jaune
une rencontre